okay now what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to show you how can you you can use
these this this whole new foundation we
have just built right it's like um it's
like everything you knew like forget
everything you knew it's not it's a bit
of an exaggeration the right angle
triangles hiding in there right it's
just we don't need to draw him anymore
I'm going to show you how you can use
this knowledge to expand our use of
trigonometry immensely okay just by
using the lens of these questions that
are in nine or five okay so let's just
have a look at the first question
we'll just do one example and then
actually you guys are going to help me
because I'm not gonna go back and forth
well do one example from each of the
questions just so you can see how it
works okay so I think in 1a they tell
you values for sine a and cause a they
tell you that right what are they
thank you and very much so they give you
these two values they draw no triangle
they don't tell you about any triangle
but we now understand that's because you
don't have to have a triangle to use
trigonometry okay which is kind of
mind-blowing because it's all that
triangle measurement so there's no
triangle here then they ask you for 10a
now we need to think okay well if we're
not just finding 10a is opposite on
adjacent because there's no triangle how
else do we define it look up tan is
defined redefined as say signed on cos
okay well I know what sine and cos are
equal to they just supplied me those
values so therefore sine on cause look
at what happens to the denominators the
denominators are just gonna cancel so
you get left with 60 on 91 . that's it
okay no triangle required right cuz
that's sine on cause the 109s are just
gonna cancel each other out that's why I
don't write them okay so you can see
trigonometry is now expanding beyond
just the the confines of a triangle okay
let's have a look at no one to
hey okay we're gonna do a few here
because we're gonna need to think about
this one
so sign what is it sign 95 okay
now by the way to help us air to these
next questions you're actually going to
need to draw another little this one can
be smaller
another little Cartesian plane below
where we did this big one so it doesn't
have to be as huge you don't have to
actually even draw a circle on it so
we'll come to that I mean up look at to
a can you read the quick read the
wording of the question for me read the
wording
it says stay aware that each acute or
obtuse angle is positive or negative now
you didn't even understand that question
yet cuz like how does that make sense
all of the angles like they're all
positive aren't they what they mean is
is sine of the angle positive or is cos
of the angle positive okay so let me
help you understand actually I'm just
I'm not even going to write an equal
sign Shh
okay come back to your original circle
okay think about this angle now 95
degrees it can't be in a triangle that's
right angled but it can be on the unit
circle where would 95 degrees be think
about it now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to in fact I'll use this I'm going
to start like my definition says I'm
going to start from the positive x-axis
here it is and then I'm going to rotate
95 degrees and I'm rotating
anti-clockwise okay
so off I go I go I hit 45 around there
and then I've hit 90 here and so 95
years just a little bit further do you
agree
okay now think about it I'm just going
to draw an approximation for where it is
let's let's say 95 is like here okay
sine of ninety five is one of the
coordinates of this point which come on
is it X or Y
it's the y-coordinate okay so you can
see I don't know what the actual value
is but clearly the white corn is up so
it's a positive number
do you agree it's positive so sine of 95
I don't know what its actual number is
but the question only wants to know is
it is it positive or is it negative well
it's up it's above the x-axis so clear
it's positive can I just do one more
question before you run so need actually
do these have a look at let's do C let's
do C 10 of what's the angle
101 53 okay now I promise this will be
really quick just so I know you got to
get out of here so do i 153 where is a
hundred and fifty three well you start
here and you start to go around right
now where 153 B it should be somewhere
around here I guess ish right now a 10
think fig fig fig fig Tan is sign over
cause do you agree right well if it's
signer because is sign positive or
negative over here it's positive cause
look it's up right
what about close is cos positive or
negative over here
it's the x-coordinate and this is on the
left so it's negative so you've got a
positive divided by a negative what's
that there's your answer
okay